francia retira todas las restricciones
en la frontera con reino unido pero
pedirá pruebas pcr en la decisión
llegada después de que una veintena de
estados suspendieron sus conexiones con
las islas británicas ante la nueva
variante del coi 19 detectadas en el
país tendremos reportes desde londres la
mutación del corona virus desafía a
farmacéutica hacia las autoridades
sanitarias que buscan generar confianza
en las vacunas y ahora el máximo
epidemiólogo de eeuu se inmunizó hoy
mientras que desde variante que aseguran
estar confiados en que su vacuna sería
efectiva contra la nueva variante del
virus detectada en reino unido- y por su
parte la compañía moderna también se
prepara para ver si su fármaco funciona
ante estas mutaciones
a las cuartas elecciones generales en
tan sólo dos años del próximo 23 de
marzo el parlamento del país se disolvió
esta madrugada luego de que el cuerpo
legislativo no alcanzara un acuerdo
sobre la fecha límite para aprobar el
presupuesto general del estado
hola muy buenas noches estamos de
regreso con más noticias en france 24
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos
santiago list ya comenzamos esta emisión
en francia- que está levantando ya a
partir de esta medianoche todas las
restricciones que mantenía en la
frontera con reino unido aunque va a
exigir ahora más para el ingreso a su
territorio una prueba pcr con resultado
negativo esta decisión llega después de
que varios países de la unión europea
apoyaran la reapertura de las fronteras
con reino unido siguiendo la
recomendación que hizo la comisión
europea después de que una veintena de
estados suspendieron sus conexiones con
las islas británicas y esto ante la
nueva variante del 'hobbit' 19 detectada
en el país desde londres nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido nos amplía la
información
se espera que este miércoles empiece a
restablecerse el tránsito de personas y
de bienes entre el reino unido y
francia- suspendido desde el domingo por
la aparición aquí en gran bretaña de un
nuevo tipo de coronavirus el acuerdo
alcanzado establece que los primeros en
viajar por tierra mar y aire serán
ciudadanos franceses residentes y
viajeros esenciales también se establece
que quienes quieran viajar deben
presentar una prueba negativa el
coronavirus 72 horas antes del viaje en
el caso de los conductores de camiones y
de tractomulas surge una pregunta
logística en dónde y quién hará estas
pruebas lo cierto es que aquí en
reinounido la situación es bien
preocupante hay al menos tres mil
camiones apostados a lo largo y ancho de
la autopista en el puerto de dover no
han podido moverse y la preocupación
entre la población es que va a suceder
con los alimentos frescos las frutas y
las verduras cuyo 50% proviene de países
europeos la gente ya está saliendo a los
supermercados a hacer compras
a funk ante el temor de que se queden
sin estos suplementos para navidad y de
fin de año por eso la urgencia de llegar
a un acuerdo entre tanto y la pregunta
también es aquí será que estas escenas
se van a repetir si no hay un acuerdo
entre el reino unido y la unión europea
para una salida negociada de la unión
europea estamos a pocos días de que se
venza este periodo de transición y
todavía no hay humo blanco de si habrá o
no habrá acuerdo y precisamente en este
contexto los estados miembros de la
unión europea planean comenzar a vacunar
a sus respectivos ciudadanos este
próximo domingo en medio de la
desconfianza en la inoculación generada
por esta nueva variante de el
coronavirus kobe 19 que fue detectada en
reino unido- y desde la farmacéutica
alemana bayón tec aseguraron estar
confiados en que su vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 desarrollada junto a facer sea
efectiva ante esta nueva cepa así lo
afirmó el propio cofundador de la
compañía okur sahin quien además agregó
que considera que podría rediseñar la
vacuna en seis semanas para adaptarla
aunque se requieren todavía más estudios
para estar completamente seguros sobre
además la compañía moderna también se
está preparando para ver si su fármaco
funciona ante esta nueva variante de el
coronavirus los detalles no los cuenta
natalia plazas un nuevo reto en la lucha
contra el coronavirus pzifer y variante
que empezaron a probar la eficacia de
sus respectivas vacunas frente a la
nueva cepa de coronavirus hallada en
reino unido
que estamos seguros de que será el caso
ya que en el pasado hemos probado más de
20 variantes de virus con diferentes
tipos de mutaciones y el resultado
siempre fue que la vacuna indujo la
respuesta inmune que es tan amplia que
ataca múltiples posiciones en esta
proteína del virus y sólo tiene que
calcular el 99 por ciento de esta
proteína
colet vietnam tiene presentes varios
potentes países se declaró optimista
pero aclaró que podría rediseñar su
vacuna en seis semanas en caso de que no
funcione y en un intento de dar
confianza a los ciudadanos algunos de
los principales funcionarios de atención
médica de eeuu fueron inoculados con una
primera dosis de la vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 de la multinacional moderna
es tan importante o más importante que
es un símbolo para todo el país que
siente una confianza extrema en la
seguridad y eficacia de esta vacuna y
quiero animar a todos los que tienen la
oportunidad de vacunarse para que
podamos tener un vuelo de protección
sobre este país que acabaría esta
pandemia es vender el llamado de los
funcionarios se da en medio de una
campaña para incentivar la vacunación
masiva en eeuu y en medio del aumento de
la desconfianza en parte de la población
respecto a recibir fármacos
desarrollados en tiempo récord y a
medida que los gobiernos a lo largo de
todo el mundo se inician sus planes de
vacunación masiva en lo que es la
carrera para volver a la normalidad les
proponemos conocer cuál es el panorama
de lo que se sabe hasta el momento
acerca de la nueva variante del
coronavirus kobe 19 en el continente
africano
en este informe de 'sebastián' espinoza
primero en europa y ahora en áfrica una
nueva variante del coronavirus fue
reportada en sudáfrica a finales de la
semana pasada el gobierno anunció que la
variante 501 v2 del cobi 19 generó un
récord en hospitalizaciones durante los
últimos días 8500 personas fueron
internadas superando el registro más
alto reportado en agosto sin precisión
sobre el efecto de la severidad de la
nueva cepa las autoridades aún no
determinan las consecuencias de la
segunda ola en su población
literalmente todo lo que sabemos es que
tenemos estas mutaciones no hemos
realizado estudios funcionales no hemos
hecho escuadrones de estudios para
determinar cómo esta variante podría
afectar la severidad de la enfermedad
cómo podría afectar su transmisión o
incluso la virulencia del virus
esta tendría una propagación más rápida
y una mayor carga de virus en las
pruebas de hisopados realizadas israel
turquía arabia saudita y alemania
cancelaron vuelos desde y hacia
sudáfrica con más de 930.000 casos y
cerca de 25.000 muertes por el patógeno
el gobierno introdujo nuevas medidas de
confinamiento
como el límite de horas y días para
vender alcohol y el cierre de algunas
playas entretanto surgen temores por un
posible confinamiento se preocupan por
la economía y si regresamos a un
confinamiento nuestra economía estará
comprometida vimos lo que hizo a inicios
de este año a su minita muchos negocios
cerraron muchos perdieron sus empleos y
eso no es bueno la gente tiene familia
tiene personas que debe cuidar así que
si vamos a donde estábamos creo que será
un gran golpe para la economía según
especialistas las mutaciones son un
proceso normal en el desarrollo de los
virus con la promesa de una vacuna que
también funcione para estas variantes el
llamado es a no bajar la guardia
y en otras noticias la escena política
de israel vuelve a verse sacudida y es
que ahora el parlamento del país se
disolvió esta madrugada y la nación
celebrará elecciones anticipadas el
próximo 23 de marzo luego de que el
cuerpo legislativo no alcanzará un
acuerdo sobre la fecha límite para
aprobar el presupuesto general estatal
la falta de acuerdo entre el primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu y sus socios
de gobierno benny ganz derivó en la
disolución automática de la cámara esta
medianoche el rabel deberá ahora ir a
sus cuartas elecciones en sólo dos años
y no tenía ilusiones con respecto a
netanyahu sabía de su historial como
violador de promesas en serie
hot city a la junio de que estamos en
contra de las elecciones es una decisión
incorrecta por parte del partido azul y
blanco pero si fuerzan otros comicios
prometo que los ganaremos el trabajo
mucho avanzamos con noticias de américa
latina colombia expulsó del país a dos
diplomáticos de la embajada rusa en
bogotá que ejecutaban actividades
incompatibles esto según el ministerio
de exteriores colombiano las autoridades
no explicaron cuáles eran esas
actividades de los diplomáticos rusos
pero según medios locales los servicios
de inteligencia colombianos habrían
detectado que estaban haciendo espionaje
en infraestructuras energéticas y
petroleras del país desde la cancillería
de colombia señalaron que la decisión ha
sido respondida recíprocamente por el
gobierno de la federación rusa al
disponer a su vez el retiro de dos
diplomáticos colombianos acreditados en
moscú
y finalizamos esta emisión con el
espíritu navideño de parís a medida que
se acerca a la navidad en medio de
estrictas restricciones por la pandemia
de coronavirus kobe 19 las luces
festivas y las decoraciones de las
calles en la capital francesa iluminan y
dan color a un muy particular fin de año
que no tendrá los tradicionales ni
grandes festejos ni tampoco las grandes
reuniones con mascarillas los residentes
de parís se tomaron fotos en el
iluminado ayuntamiento de la ciudad
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
otra emisión informativa pero los
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
[Música]